[Musique]
vous venez de voir un extrait de
flonflons et mu est une création de la
compagnie o'navio un thème dur destiné
aux enfants mélanie vous êtes allé la
voir
oui alors flonflons et vous êtes une
petite bulle des lic délicate d'une
trentaine de minutes c'est à voir en
famille dès l'âge de 4 ans à l'origine
un album écrit par esb et à auteur et
illustratrice jeunesse franco polonaise
flonflons et musette ce sont deux d'où
on les voit à l'écran jeu des lapins et
c'est surtout des enfants qui subissent
la décision des gros j'ai l'impression
ça c'est pas parce qu'on fait de l'art
du théâtre jeune public ne peut pas
parler de sujets graves et s'éteint
c'est un livre qui en parlent en tout
cas c'est une histoire qui parle de ces
sujets là de la guerre de séparation
mais qui on parle aussi beaucoup de joie
et espoir voilà cet accès malgré un
sujet un peu difficile c'est pour moi
c'est pas un spectacle noir donc pas un
spectacle noir lancée même drôle moi
quand je suis allé les enfants riaient
beaucoup jetons nous aide c'est avant
tout une histoire d'amitié voire un
petit peu plus regardées
[Musique]
marie ouais mais comment faire alors
pour découvrir à l'histoire de flonflons
et mieux-être
rendez vous à la maison de quartier
joseph kosma de guyancourt ça se passe
ce samedi 11 novembre à 15 heures le
spectacle est proposé par la ferme de
bel ébat merci mélanie comme toujours
pour vos idées sorties junior